atentos a esta pregunta quién diría es
que es el mayor aliado de eeuu es canadá
tal vez de reino unido puede que israel
no es una pregunta nada fácil y desde
luego depende de que preguntemos y a
quien preguntemos pero hay un país que
ha sumado muchos puntos en los últimos
años hasta tal punto que para los
republicanos hoy ya es el mayor aliado
de eeuu el mejor amigo por encima de
cualquier otro país y no no es canadá ni
reino unido es australia el país del sur
los canguros y la ópera de sydney
sorprendidos pues no deberíais estarlo
si tenemos en cuenta amigos de visual
polític que australia es el único país
del mundo que ha luchado con eeuu en
todas sus grandes contiendas en las dos
guerras mundiales en corea y en vietnam
en la guerra del golfo en afganistán en
irak y también ahora en las operaciones
contra el estado islámico vamos casi
podemos decir que para el pentágono los
australianos son los que luka modric se
saldrá en madrid es un jugador que puede
pasar desapercibido pero siempre es
titular indiscutible
pues bien pese a todo esto el pasado 28
de enero de 2017
donald trump le colgó el teléfono al
mismísimo primer ministro de australia
malcom árbol y no sólo eso antes de
mandarle a paseo y colgarla el teléfono
trump le acusó de querer exportar
terroristas a eeuu y todo por un acuerdo
de poco peso al que habían llegado los
dos países un acuerdo que implicaba que
eeuu acogería a 1250 refugiados pero esa
es otra historia que contaremos en otro
vídeo si puede parecer un suceso
anecdótico pero ha provocado que muchos
australianos se pregunten si no es ya la
hora de echarle un poco de hielo a tanto
amiguismo
[Música]
pues bien todo esto nos ha hecho
hacernos unas cuantas preguntas cómo de
importante es australia para eeuu tiene
sentido que trump le colgara el teléfono
a su mayor aliado qué consecuencias
puede tener pues bien vayamos a verlo
el tiempo de asia no es nada nuevo y
desde luego todos aquellos que nos
seguís habitualmente lo sabéis bien el
mundo ha cambiado y tanto el peso del
poder político como del poder económico
se están desplazando a toda velocidad
hacia asia aproximadamente para 2020 más
de la mitad de toda la economía y de
toda la población mundial se
concentrarán en este continente y desde
luego la emergencia de china como nueva
superpotencia es todo un hecho hasta
hace poco este era el mapa del mundo más
común verdad pues a partir de ahora
veremos cada vez más este otro como veis
europa deja de estar en el centro del
mundo para pasar a estar en una esquina
desde luego en la práctica esto no es
más que una anécdota pero no me negaréis
que es todo un símbolo de cómo están
cambiando las cosas no os parece estoy
diciendo que alemania no está donde creo
nada está donde creer dónde está buena
pregunta no hay duda el siglo 21 será el
tiempo de la gran transformación de asia
en este siglo veremos a muchos países
convertirse en auténticas potencias
mundiales porque ojo cuando
de asia no sólo hablamos de china
hablamos también de países como vietnam
indonesia filipinas y por supuesto la
india
precisamente por este motivo el anterior
presidente de los eeuu barack obama
decidió apostar fuerte por así convertir
a este continente en la prioridad número
uno de la diplomacia estadounidense y es
que precisamente bajo estas
circunstancias es donde australia de
repente se ha convertido en un amigo muy
valioso pero hasta dónde llega la
amistad entre eeuu y australia
veámoslo
gran aliado
en noviembre de 2011 barack obama y la
entonces primer ministro de australia
julia gillard firmaron un tratado
militar que supuso llevar la cooperación
en defensa entre ambos países a una
nueva dimensión casi podemos decir que
con este acuerdo amigos daba comienzo
todo un noviazgo en materia militar
entre eeuu y australia
de hecho fijaros como describió el 'new
york times' este acuerdo el acuerdo
firmado con australia suponen la primera
expansión de la presencia militar de
eeuu en el pacífico desde el final de la
guerra de vietnam pero que implicaba
realmente este acuerdo de entrada
gracias al tratado firmado entre
australia y eeuu la potencia
norteamericana puede desplegar en
australia una fuerza de combate que se
irá incrementando progresivamente hasta
alcanzar los 2.500 soldados
pertenecientes al cuerpo de marines es
decir el cuerpo de combate que tiene la
misión de desplegarse rápidamente en
caso de conflicto pero ésta sólo es una
parte muy limitada de la historia porque
lo cierto es que desde entonces la
colabora
entre ambos países no ha dejado de
crecer y crecer hasta el punto que hoy
para washington la relación con su socio
australiano se ha convertido casi en
imprescindible porque amigos de visual
político no sólo se trata de los marines
los eeuu quieren convertir a este país
en la base de operaciones clave para sus
actividades en el océano pacifico y
también en el químico para que os hagáis
una idea eeuu quiere tener acceso a
pistas de aterrizaje en el norte del
país quiere desplegar en un solo
australiano bombarderos b-2 y vez 52
quiere también fijar cerca de perth en
el extremo occidental de australia una
enorme base naval para su flota de
portaaviones y submarinos nucleares
y más eeuu también tiene intención de
situar aquí centros de vigilancia aérea
e instalaciones de alerta de
lanzamientos de misiles e incluso quiere
alquilar parte de estas islas las islas
cocos un remoto enclave en el índico de
soberanía australiana
[Música]
y estaréis pensando como como alquilar
unas islas para que vean tres quiere
eeuu unas islas perdidas en el índico
pues la respuesta es clara eeuu quiere
situar en las islas cocos aviones de
vigilancia de largo alcance drones
armados y en caso de guerra utilizar
este archipiélago como centro de
despegue para sus bombarderos y sabéis
que esto no acaba aquí porque por
supuesto eeuu también quiere mejorar la
integración entre su ejército y las
fuerzas armadas australianas para en
caso de necesidad estar listos para
operar conjuntamente hasta el momento la
parte australiana ha sido muy receptiva
a las intenciones de eeuu y ya se han
dado pasos de gigante de hecho australia
ha lanzado en los últimos años una gran
renovación de sus equipos militares
hablamos de contratos de compra de miles
y miles de millones de dólares entre los
que por supuesto hay mucho material
estadounidense por ejemplo el
controvertido f-35 del que australia se
ha comprometido a comprar 72 unidades
que le van a costar ni más ni menos que
la fabulosa cifra de 17.000
de dólares ojo hablamos de un país de
poco más de 24 millones de habitantes
así que no está nada mal por cierto así
despegan los nuevos juguetes del
ejército australiano
[Música]
y con todo esto puede que ahora lo que
os estéis preguntando es y porque
australia pues por varias razones
primero porque ambos países son
culturalmente muy cercanos y como hemos
visto antes ya han combatido muchas
veces juntos segundo porque australia
tiene un enclave geográfico casi
perfecto se encuentra entre el pacífico
y el índico a una distancia suficiente
de los enclaves calientes de asia como
para poder realizar ataques o desplegar
tropas relativamente rápido
y por último un tercer factor decisivo
australia es en estos momentos un
importante proveedor de energía materias
primas y alimentos para china en caso de
conflicto o de tensiones fuertes el
control de australia podría ser una
primera ventaja para eeuu
[Música]
pero qué pasa con la otra parte que
quieren los australianos pues
básicamente entienden que eeuu es para
ellos una especie de póliza de seguro
que les garantiza su seguridad sin
embargo empiezan a escucharse cada vez
más voces que no están muy de acuerdo
con esta tesis y desde luego el que
trump le colgase el teléfono a su primer
ministro ha dado mucha energía a este
movimiento
la alternativa china
china se ha convertido con mucha
diferencia en el mayor socio comercial
de australia es el primer destino de sus
exportaciones el país de origen de
muchos de los inmigrantes que han
llegado a esta isla continente y además
cada año son más los chinos que llegan a
hacer turismo oa estudiar vamos que los
chinos suponen mucho dinerito para los
australianos y eso tiene consecuencias
en 2014 el lobby institute para la
política internacional le pregunto a los
australianos sobre cuál debía ser el
socio más importante para australia y
eeuu o china
en aquella ocasión la potencia
norteamericana ganó por 11 puntos en
2016 sin embargo hubo un empate y ojo
los menores de 45 años se inclinaron
claramente por china su país debía
distanciarse de un eeuu liderado por
donald trump en esta línea que
básicamente apuesta por más china y
menos eeuu está por ejemplo paul keating
un importante ex primer ministro del que
os hablamos hace muy poco atentos a cómo
justifica su posición nuestra sociedad
es mejor que la de eeuu es más uniforme
es más
está en los últimos 20 años nuestros
ingresos han aumentado un 50 por ciento
en eeuu prácticamente nada de momento lo
que sí que ha hecho australia es hacer
muchos guiños al gigante asiático por
ejemplo y para disgusto de washington el
país decidió participar en el banco
asiático de inversión en
infraestructuras una institución
liderada por china y con la que pekín
quiere incrementar su influencia en el
continente y desde el propio gobierno
australiano se ha dejado claro que china
es sobre todo una gran fuente de
oportunidades para colmo últimamente
eeuu no hace más que darle disgustos a
los australianos cuando por ejemplo
donald trump decidió tumbar el pp
dejando fuera a eeuu el gobierno de
australia que había sido un firme
partidario del tratado no sólo mostró su
decepción sino que suministra de
exteriores
julie bishop dijo que estaba estudiando
incluso sugerir al resto de miembros que
china ocupase el puesto de eeuu por
suerte para los estadounidenses aún son
muchos los lazos que protegen la alianza
con australia de personajes como donald
trump
[Música]
la cultura estadounidense y el miedo al
dragón chino
australia y eeuu son política cultural y
económicamente países muy similares
tanto que no es extraño que a nivel
internacional se considere que australia
es una prolongación del modo de vida de
la identidad estadounidense en asia y
desde luego los australianos aún están
muy orgullosos de esta consideración
pase lo que pase no se apagará mi afecto
por el pueblo estadounidense y lo mejor
de la cultura norteamericana no me críe
en eeuu pero me crié en el siglo
estadounidense además eeuu sigue con
diferencia siendo el mayor inversor en
australia una inversión que por cierto
supera atentos los 500 mil millones de
dólares también el hecho de que china
continúe siendo una dictadura es algo
que genera muchos recelos en australia
donde muchos no se fían de las
intenciones de pekín en esta línea el
gobierno ha vetado varias operaciones de
inversores chinos que quieren comprar
tierras en australia así que bien
podemos decir que si algo parece
predecible es que hoy por hoy la alianza
con eeuu va a continuar pero
también que los australianos son muy
pragmáticos y tienen muy claro que no
quieren verse afectados por una guerra
de poder entre china y eeuu bueno y a
todo esto tú qué piensas
crees que eeuu conseguirá a pesar de
donald trump sacar adelante todos sus
proyectos en australia o por el
contrario china irá cobrando cada vez
más y más influencia y si trump le
colgase el teléfono a tu país como te lo
tomarías deja nuestra opinión en los
comentarios y como dice simon si te ha
gustado este vídeo levantas los pulgares
dándole al botón de like como aún no
sabes quién es simon bueno no te
preocupes porque tiene remedio haz click
aquí y suscríbete a nuestro canal en
inglés para conocerle un saludo y hasta
la próxima
qué posibilidades tienes de salir de
aquí con esa chaqueta pues ter
sí claro
más de una
[Música]